as a director what is your process for
looking through a screenplay before
production and making it a better story
mm well I've never read a screenplay
that I didn't think needed some sort of
tweak I've never read a script ins been
like that is the perfect screenplay
because I think that it is true that
every work of art including screenplays
because they are a work of art can find
something within it that you can change
or modify or improve because every
person that reads something brings a
whole different set of experiences to
what they're reading and so for me when
I look at a script I'm looking for a
couple of things I'm looking for
characterization how do the characters
evolve as we're reading the screenplay
what did they start out with and where
do they end up secondly how does that
characterization tie into the theme of
the screenplay what are the themes of
the screenplay if your screenplay is
effective the themes and
characterization should weave together
seamlessly because the characters
develop the theme and the themes develop
the character and the next thing I'm
going to look for what I'm reading that
script what is the pace at which it
unfolds is it moving at a speed that
makes sense is it too slow is it too
fast and where places that that staccato
kind of messes up where is it that
doesn't necessarily work and so I'm
going to work with the riders to try to
find a way to blend that pace evenly
throughout a screenplay because if it
doesn't work on the page as the old
adage says it's not going to work on the
screen because you can't fix it as
you're filming it it's a very difficult
process to do I have rewritten
screenplays as I film before and it's a
horrible horrible way to go about
production so you've got to find those
things at the onset and so for me it's
always about finding the character
finding the theme and finding the pace
because if you do those three things in
a script you'll probably find it to be
effective
you